members of the council ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this evening's
meeting of
the southeast area planning committee
agenda item one is chairman's notices
um my name is councillor duik and i'm
chairman of this committee
uh remember to be aware we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
it and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones
therefore can i ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
gender item two apologies for absence uh
bernard do we have any
chairman yesterday
thank you thank you very much
agenda item three minutes of the last
meeting
to confirm the minutes of the meeting of
the committee held on the 6th of april
of this year
which is to be found on pages 7 to 18.
agreed are we happy
thank you very much
a gender item for disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests on
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
uh councillors cancer schemes what
around the room
uh yes uh
in the room uh a couple of architects
who are uh
taking part in items which item it was i
think it's uh item eight
uh but either way i know them as family
friends but there's no pecuniary
interest
thank you that's the voice um
non-pecuniary interest agenda item five
christmas stone
uh thank you chairman um i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest as a
member of essex county council a
statutory council t on all planning
related matters okay thank you very much
uh cancer fluker
and thank you chairman um
sunnyside stony hills chairman i i'm
acquainted with the agent
yes i'm in the same position cancer helm
item five non-keto interest global curve
solicitor last time about it
so on item seven i am a friend of the
owner of the clubhouse
non-pecuniary right thank you
anybody else
no right gender item five
uh it's the land to rear of red lines
from burner road latching down
uh we originally looked at this
application in december last year
when the committee deferred it for
further information
uh since then and now the
applicants have gone to appeal so we
cannot make a decision but your views
are requested so that the council can
use those views at
the appeal in whatever shape it may take
cancer boys
i don't know whether i'm jumping in
front of the presentation um
but
i think there's a
in my mind there's a confusion of why it
was deferred
um the report says that it was deferred
for the applicant to give us information
i believed that the deferral was for our
officers to give us information but i
looked to councillor fluka to see
i i believe you're a correct counselor
boys but my memory doesn't seem to last
much longer than a fortnight so going
back six months best part i really
haven't got a clue but i believe you are
correct on that yes
any other members on this
castle's games only that i just what
you believe
only that i just watched the officers
shaking their heads so maybe they should
have something to say on
mr boy's uh councillor boyce's
point
okay
all right shall we go with the
presentation first yes please
so through your term and thank you
so
the site is located to the south of
second the south of burnham road outside
the southern boundary of lansington uh
israel lions farm and it comprises
mixed-use business park
which sees an undesignated employment
sites
the current application relates to unit
10 as you can see here
and on those plans
and these are some photographs of the
site we've been through all that so i
don't think there is a reason to revisit
unless members want to
um see some of the photographs and i can
explain that further later on
so the the
application the original application was
sort and sort of permission
for the variation of condition two of
the original permission which was
fourteen slash zero zero four one eight
slash ful
and to
alter the permitted working hours from
six to eight on monday to saturday
so the application was presented as
council of duik said on the 8th of
december to
the southwest committee and the
committee deferred the ad the item in
order to give the applicant the
opportunity to provide additional
information and clarity in relation to
various matters including noise
and the land the lawful use of the site
no further information in relation to
the deferral reason was submitted by the
a great extended time period and
although a number of attempts attempts
were made by the council to engage with
the applicant no response was received
confirming whether the additional
information that we're expecting were
going to be submitted on the 5th of
april
this year a letter was received from the
planning inspectorate confirming the
validity of an appeal for a
non-determination
in relation to this application
based on that the local planning
authorities doesn't no longer have
control over the determination of the
application
as always stated
which will be determined by the planning
inspectorate
however councils the council's intention
to either approve or refuse the
application would be requested by the
planning inspectorate as part of the
appeal process
so
the officers report the original
officer's report is included within
appendix a
also the
updated report includes a
information in relation to enforcement
matters
on page 21 however it should be noted
that matters relevant to enforcement
either on the application side or the
wider business park
are not considered to be a material
consideration relevant to the
determination of the current application
so for the reasons explained and
previously discussed in the previous
meeting
members are requested to agree whether
we would be minded
to approve the application as suggested
by the
by officers subject to conditions which
are included on pages 23 to 32 of the
agenda
and also the additional condition aid
included into the members update as it
was submitted for the
committee meeting on the 8th of december
securing the submission of a noise
report assessing the combined noise
emissions from all sources at the site
and the wider area
thank you
we have one person who was registered to
speak in person
and that is an objective mr david
bennett mr bennett
um i believe you need to get to a
microphone somewhere
you have two minutes to state your case
at the time you start speaking and at
the end of the two minutes your time is
up thank you
the original noise report associated to
this application was a rehashed report
that was submitted in a previous
application to seek planning for an
additional 20 units on this site the
environmental health officer eventually
raised an issue around the validity of
the noise report and deemed it was not
suitable for this application as it
measured noise at the entrance of the
business park and not the noise from the
unit itself
this application for garage auto repair
business is now being considered against
a backdrop of other approved
applications that were approved we've
invented my environmental health failing
to highlight the same irrelevant noise
report was used to add weight to those
applications too in the last meeting
where this application was debated the
chairman cited that he was surprised by
the hours afforded this business park as
they fought as they are far and above
anything else in essex and councillors
also stated they wouldn't want to live
next door to the business part with
these operating hours mr lee stated that
the application was for the unit itself
and not the business occupying it
if this is the case and this unit can be
for any business how can environmental
health determine there will be no impact
on our well-being or request a condition
for a noise report to be carried out for
the current business who even the
council believe are operating their in
breach of planning control would this
happen every time someone moved into the
unit if the site is a distribution site
with lorries coming in from 6am to 8pm
with a forklift operating 14 hours a day
six days a week would this not impact us
conditions haven't been enforced for
over three years so what would change
the business park entrance is one meter
from our property the unit in question
operates 10 meters from our property if
your neighbor cuts his lawn you can put
up with the noise on the odd weekend but
every day 14 hours a day from over 15
units there are cars being revved up
industrial noise lorries and deliveries
from 6am to 8pm six days a week where is
our time to relax and enjoy our home a
further 20 units are planned for this
site we can't even have our windows open
in the summer because of the noise
policy d1 and the cumulative effect of
noise was mentioned at the last meeting
we believe that a reasonable noise level
has already been exceeded and would urge
the council to reject this application
request totally unreasonable operating
hours and remove our basic right to
enjoy our home and guide it your time is
up thank you thank you
all right to ward members if you speak
first cancer boyce
um
thank you chairman um at some stage i'd
like members recollections of why it was
deferred last time
um
but
for the moment
um
the
um
b1 is a light use suitable in a
residential area
this
is a residential area this must be the
first
thing that we look at that
it is a residential area
um and
ours are not suitable
uh uh
these sort of hours are not suitable in
a residential area as the objector has
just said i think mentioned 14 hours and
this now is six days a week not five and
a half days and bank holidays because it
doesn't exclude that
thank you for that uh
uh elucidation chairman um
what we've got is a situation where the
conditions do not seem to be enforceable
and
i think
that the
noise
that's created by some of these uses now
i know somebody's going to tell me that
we must only look at the unit that the
application is for which i accept but
the officer does use other units
to make the case
for
recommending approval
so i don't see why
we
as a planning committee cannot use other
evidence from the other units
to
support a rejection of the officer's
recommendation
um
again we must remember we're looking at
a rural area not an urban area where
background noises may be um higher than
in a rural area
um i think
that
um
i have
a great sympathy uh with the objector on
this so therefore i will not actually
vote
on this because it may be determined
that i've got a bias
i don't think i have
but
but i'm i've so i will not
vote on it
it is i think
a case
that i would support
if they
uh objected
and there is other residents there made
a case of the local government ombudsman
not on the decision
but the
local planning authority's failure to
deal with all the issues
uh on this site
and
as it's going to an inspector can i ask
that the local planning authority asked
for a hearing to to hear this appeal
thank you chairman okay thank you so
much cancer fluker
there's no other
board member present okay
um thank you
could we just go to
the the site plan
please
my understanding is to the
to the right
of the site where that light green blob
is
there's planning permission there for
a very large
bungalow so you've actually got
so you've you've actually got the
prophecies on
the main road and then below that you've
also got a residential development
coming forward i i don't see anything
mentioned in the world about that but
chairman i mean we're beginning to
understand quite clearly after childhood
the modus operandi of pins since the
fact that they listen to the recordings
of
these meetings now and i'm pleased they
do
um so cheerful chairman mindful of that
um
i i would
ask
that if this planning application was
approved there were additional
conditions attached to protect the local
residents the first one being
um to protect the community of local
residents when the premises are in use
all exterior doors and shutters are
closed
prior to any machinery being used and
works carried out i mean that's solely
for the purpose of protecting the
immunity and also chairman given
given the difference of opinion over
noise
um i think that if we were determining
this and we were minded to approve it
then i think we'd condition it two years
approval anyway so i i hope that's
picked up by the officers and i hope
that's picked up by anybody else that
might listen to this tape but my main
point is chairman
um i'm i'm i'm sure that all of the
members here tonight have read
mr kant's report
to mr miss tatsuglu
uh and just for your reference dated the
7th of december 2021
and this is a document that's on the
website gentlemen i hope you're
me
these are the words of our environmental
health officer the noise assessment
submitted with this application is the
same as the ones used for applications
for other units in a different area of
red lines business part
i am not satisfied that it is adequately
assesses the noise from unit 10
at present and we therefore
can't know the impact of the proposed
change of hours
i mean to me chairman that's pretty cut
and
try had this assessment been submitted
in respect to unit 10 in isolation and
remember these aren't my words these are
the morton district council
environmental health officer
i would particularly have a question the
selection of the monitoring position i
believe that further assessment
specifically relating to unit number 10
is required
so i've read german the the applicant's
noise survey from sharps a company
called sharps i think about 80 percent
of that tells you more about how they
did it as opposed to what their outcomes
were
uh and the only thing they seem to
mention uh is about the noise the gates
going to make so the officers have
picked up on that and in fact the
environmental health officer
has said well if we were minded to prove
it then we should and the officer nods
but you can't nod based on the first
paragraph because the officer does not
agree to this there is no there's no
newer report he doesn't support the way
the noise assessment was done and as far
as uh enforcement i think the officers
quite like chairman to say that we
shouldn't take this consideration but i
think it's also useful to see what the
environmental health officer says in his
report because he speaks to endorsement
he speaks to noise and then he says but
they do not
but they do help to provide some useful
context so what he's saying is look
there's a lot of enforcement here about
noise whilst you can't accept it from a
planning point of view they still
provide a useful context when
considering noise on the site
so chairman i i really don't get this
because when this was deferred i was i
was expecting chairman to seize a lot
more
information more up-to-date information
chairman and and as far as i remember
chairman i um i think that's what this
committee asked for yet the latest
document on there is from i don't know
four and a half months ago so chairman i
i
i genuinely don't believe that we can
determine this
i i agree with what council boyce says i
think that we should have uh this
shouldn't be done by an exchange of
papers
we we we should actually have an inquiry
and and i think we need to get to the
bottom of this because um
from what the objective says this is not
right next to whatever's gone on that
site in the past and if mr lee was here
tonight he would say that all
applications have to be dealt with on
their own merits
now
we've now got a situation where this
site is going to be open from six
o'clock in the morning to eight o'clock
six days a week bank holidays
uh it's not acceptable close to close to
residential properties i couldn't
support it chairman and um
and i i i would propose chair chairman
that if we're if i don't know what we're
doing here um i think it's all to do
with mindfulness looking at what we will
need to do at this stage is to make a
decision as to what we would
have done
if we were making a final decision so if
you wish to approve it you can approve
it if you wish to refuse it you can
refuse it but that will go forward as a
recommendation to the planning inspector
well chairman i i would say
we've got
a balance we've got the sharps survey
noise impact assessment here and we've
got the environmental health the morton
district council environmental health uh
comments here and i'm afraid that the
two are different and i think that based
on ours chairman
what comes from morgan district council
i would refuse it
so i'm proposing that we refuse it
okay is that a second did
that second did
i thank you um
before i move on can i just say you came
up with if it was if the inspector was
to improve it you suggested two
conditions i would like to see a third
one added to that that no that it should
actually specify
no working of this unit on a sunday or
bank holidays because at the moment bank
holidays as far as i can tell it
completely excluded from the
um from the whole thing which
it seems to me quite extraordinary but
still before i take any other members
and that you wish to come back on yes
please yeah thank you chairman yeah i'd
like to come back to some of the points
that council of florida raised
um
just a little a little bit of background
when the application was originally
submitted and we received comments from
the
environmental health officer there was
no objection similar to
[Music]
the response that we've received for
other
um
other alterations to conditions for the
other units within the um
red lions farm we've then sought further
comments in particular in relation to
this um unit and then the comments that
council floyd may reference to were
received
so
i obviously yes i agree that he raised
concerns um in relation to the impact
but his response carries on identifying
how this could be addressed by the
imposition of a condition
when i was doing the presentation
earlier i said that officers suggest or
officers
recommended approval subject to the
conditions in the
offices report which was within the
appendix plus the condition in the
member's update which was the condition
suggested by the environmental health
officer and this had to do with the
submission of a noise report assessing
the impact from the side and the wider
area
and
i think i've covered that also just to
clarify that
we have sought from the applicant to
submit a noise assessment as it was
requested by the environmental health
environmental health officer so we would
be able to present you
um
at the following committee with more
information in relation to the noise
impacts but we've never received a
response to that
and in relation to the conditions
suggested
i believe if if members would be minded
to
approve the application subject to the
officer's
recommendation i think all three of
those would be able to
be
added
to secure residential amenity all of
those suggested and there are also
others that relate to no use of
machinery outside the site and no
storage of materials outside
no installation of plants and equipment
outside outside and
as well as um
illumination so that could be an
addition if you were minded to prove it
thank you chad i'll just clarify one
point in
[Music]
four two
if i've read it correctly you identify
the user's b2 general industrial
of that unit where the request is for
uh
says it as b1 which we don't believe it
is
through you chairman yes
in that section of the report i've
covered what the
enforcement team is currently dealing
with yes you're right the site benefits
from permission to be used as b1
actually
eg
two and three which is general
industrial and um
um
what's it called uh the
and and also
use as um resets and development so the
this is the use that they have
permission for
their
the enforcement team is dealing with
them with a complaint where
i mean obviously this will be dealt with
separately but from what we have as
information at the moment yes we think
that if
if actually the site is used as a tire
and service uh tire uh installation and
and services of vehicles then yes that
would come under b to use glass rather
than
yeah
yeah but this is a matter of conflict on
the
application itself though isn't it like
it is a matter that it has to be dealt
with separately by enforcement if they
do not comply with the condition because
there is a condition
uh
the condition one from those imposed to
this permission and previous permissions
is to be used as
eg two or three okay thank you cancer
skins and council helm
uh
really a question for the officers
uh this uh as i can understand it this
is an established uh small industrial
site or light industrial site
and so i would agree
with um
so i just want confirmation of that and
secondly
yes any restrictions that could be put
on i mean i would be tempted
i'll propose adding a restriction that
there is no uh noise on the site before
eight o'clock and after six o'clock as
well uh during the week because uh
that must be very
disturbing to the people that live
around but first of all this is an
established site there are plenty of
there are plenty of units there are
there not
are you terminally yes it is an
established site it's not an ally it's
not an existing
um
employment side within the ldp but yes
it's an established uh how does it be
established
we have applications definitely since
2001 to convert the use of the buildings
but i assume it's been operating before
that
yeah long before that i don't have the
exam yeah
cancer hill
can we have could put light on please oh
yeah
thank you mr chair for my experience
the other end of the village operating
hours are eight till six monday to
friday and eight to
twelve or one on saturday no working on
sundays no working on bank holidays and
doors to be kept shut while working
what i would question also is the
previous delegated decisions to allow
them to go from six till
eight o'clock at night who on earth
thought of that didn't they
look at their area what was going on or
did they just decide that was all right
yeah the previous delegated decisions
was were based on the
consultation response received
by the environmental health officer who
based on the noise report submitted
by sarp and found it acceptable
suggested that it was acceptable subject
to as counselor fluger said earlier a
condition in relation to
yates
casa helm again
doing this you've set a question for all
the industrial sites in the density
to operate from six o'clock in the
morning to eight o'clock at
night i don't do that and i wouldn't do
that but other people would in a great
hell with the neighbors
that's mr stan
and mine's not so much a question it's a
comment in fact that i've been living
around a building site for noise that's
been been going on three most probably
two three years and i tell you something
by
the time it comes to saturday at one
o'clock you want some peace and blooming
quiet because all you hear is the drones
of machinery whatever type of machinery
and when i was also working from home
you can't sometimes hear when you're in
a team's meeting because of the noise
and i really feel sorry for the
residents that are so close to that and
if they are changing tires and they are
they're not things because they put them
air machines in and they unscrew things
really fast or whatever they're doing
and it's intolerable and i certainly
don't think we should be setting a
precedent by saying you can operate till
8 o'clock on a saturday night because
most people have got their kids if
they've got them in bed and they want to
sit down with a bit of peace and quiet
not be able to close their windows not
to go in their greenhouses and i'm sorry
i think what this council are doing the
recommendation is not right thank you
chair it's not a comment it's a question
it's a comment
schemes uh i'd just like to propose um
an amendment that says there's no
operation of the of uh we have a
proposal duly seconded to refuse the
application yeah but uh but so i'm
saying
okay
we'll come back to you on that all right
okay all right
counselor do you wish to add anything or
can we move to a vote
oh counsel mr channel
can you
i i'm red
i meant to be ready yeah sorry i think
it's meant to be green i don't know why
i agree it should be yeah um
chairman can i just confirm that um the
officers
in the officers report talking about the
conditions
uh it refers to section eight and
there's seven conditions
and that's what you're recommending if
we were minded to approval we go with i
mean i've heard what the other
conditions are
tonight but is that what officer's view
is
three determinant the seventh plus the
eighth one on the members update
yeah the members of the previous members
update as i said in the presentation
yeah i know there's been that bit but i
would have expected to see that much
clearer possibly rather than um
previously and you know looking at the
minutes which i've got on my mobile here
from the december meeting members raised
at that time concerns about um human
rights
and it was about the noise
and the adverse impact the industrial
site has on the neighboring properties
and obviously this coming into the
equation i know you're going to tell us
we mustn't think about the whole site
and it referred to the eh
detail information dealt with and how
they considered there did need to be
this specific noise assessment and
members did request actually further
information specifically a number of
matters doesn't detail all those matters
which included noise and also the lawful
use of the site
i'm concerned about the hours of
operation
to me
they seem exceedingly long
and i think like councillor helms
pointed out
it does set a precedent dare i say
that could be reflected elsewhere
so um i i feel very much like i think
the committee did in december if i'm
frank chairman
councillor boyce no
cancer fluke did you wish to yeah
just a couple of points
for clarity um i mean i mean the obvious
question to put me off to the officer is
would you like a an impact wheel gun
going off outside your house at six
o'clock in the morning but you're saying
that i don't know
but i mean it's you know this is not red
bull this isn't 2.2 seconds and off they
go you know this is like 20 minutes to
change these things it did i don't feel
very happy about this at all but what i
wanted to ask germans in in light of
the appeal at charwood um my
understanding is the council didn't
actually
didn't actually defend that appeal
and by not defending it and i appreciate
that it was it was on paper but by not
defending it they automatically become a
hostile witness
so tell me my question is is will the
officers provide another report to pins
based on the deliberations and the
decisions of this committee
[Laughter]
i mean
again it's it's cases should be
considered on on its own basis but we i
i can't i mean we officers
support the council's decisions but
however
just just to remind you again this is
not going to be our decision this is
going to be just
what you would be minded to do so we
won't have any any control we will as a
council we will make no decision it
would be just to inform the inspectorate
what would what we would have done so if
you decide today to refuse the
application this is what we will inform
the inspectorate if you decide to if you
say that we would be minded to approve
it we will say that we the council would
be minded to approve it for that many
reasons uh subject to that many
conditions so it's it's not that we are
um to make a decision
it isn't a decision
you will present any decision that is
made tonight to the planning
inspectorate as though it was
a decision if there was a case will be
made
yeah of what this committee decides and
it will go forward to the planning
inspector yeah what would be would we be
minded as a council to whether would we
want to approve or refuse yes we'll do
that yeah
right i think can we move on because
this is we can go around a little bit in
circles we've got a proposal duly
seconded the proposal by councillor
fluge duly seconded by councilman stamp
that to refuse the application for
reasons of
unreasonable
unreasonable hours of working
with limited control something along
those lines is that correct
loss of amenity
it's a semi-residential area yeah
it's a problem with a mixed use isn't it
right those in favor of refusal please
show
three four five those against
one
in that case we will present this to the
planning inspectorate as though the
council
have refused the application council
boys
now that's concluded can uh i propose
that
we we request
a hearing
um
if that second it yeah yeah
agree yeah yeah yeah well i believe we
certainly can request a hearing i know
it's an inspectorate's final decision
but yeah
i think i think we say it's actually in
the public interest because there's
there's quite a bit of public that are
extremely interested and affected by
this and i'm sure they'd like to make
their case to the inspector
council
chairman and bearing in mind what
happened at burnham waters would it not
be prudent at this stage to say that the
the the ward members
are the lead members on this if there is
a hearing thank you
is the board member it's the world
member keen to do that
he had more time than his chairman
i i i think somebody's being evil
if
if necessary but i'm assuming that the
um the objectors would be much better
able to put their case than i would for
them
okay thank you but i mean if it's a
hearing it's a fairly uh
non-um non-critical thing isn't it
in relation to the hearing we might not
be able to have a hearing because it's
an appeal for non-determination
it's not an appeal against the decision
of the council i'm being told that
because it's
the appeal it's a non-determination it
may not be possible to have a hearing
but we can request it nevertheless can't
we
we can investigate whether this is an
option but i doubt it because there
isn't actually a decision
that's been made by the council so it's
normally um
in terms of procedural procedural
matters rather than the decision itself
all right we'll see where we go with
that cancer voice um and that also
raises the issue of why we deferred it
um in the first place um
mrs channel has
read out i think the minutes which
which indicate
um that we were expecting our officers
to come back with a further information
and if you remember chairman we have
uh or several members have constantly
been asking the officers where the
information and why this hasn't come
back um
so the
the appeal because of non-determination
is actually um
the local planning authority's fault
rather than the
applicant
counsel mr stone
thank you chairman so so just to be
clear why are we actually having to put
a recommendation forward for refusal or
approval if it's not going to be
determined on that because it's going to
be determined on whether um the planning
department here
um didn't um
non-determination so i don't understand
it it doesn't cross
pollinate what the word is to me because
you're asking us to decision and now
you're saying it's not going to be taken
forward so why are we determining
something
the decision must be taken our decision
must be taken forward to the planning
inspector and the planning inspector
will take that as part of his
information that he uses or she uses in
making a final determination
well that has always been the case every
time this has happened in the past
mr johnson
through you chair um the
the details we've received so far
regarding the appeal is that one has
been submitted
it's been checked for its validity
and the inspectorate are awaiting and
appointed sorry the inspector rich are
awaiting an appointed inspector
at that particular point that's when
the timetable process
will then
be engaged now through that timetable
process they will send us a start letter
the start letter then sets out the
procedure for the appeal now it's within
that point that's when the council can
then
um
um you know go through the usual appeal
process
so while i don't have the information in
front of me that may be the opportunity
where we can then make our own as to
what type of appeal
we would like to be considered but we
don't have that start date yet so we
don't know when it's going to stop there
is a backlog with the appeal you know
things are taking quite quite some time
but that that's that's position of that
at the moment
thank you chairman yeah well that i
believe is what members were you know
asking but when we get the opportunity
we must make the application for what
the committee decided on it
yeah through terminal in relation to the
point raised as to why we've been asked
to say why we were minded to because
this is this is what the inspectorate
asked us they would ask us what we would
be minded to do with the appeal that's
why we need to make
that
yeah you need to vote on that tonight
in effect what you're doing is you're
going back to to last december and
saying if we made a determination and
this is what we would have done
and they could then have appealed anyway
on our decision
but we but we now have a decision not
just a recommendation
council mr channel
can i just get that qualified or clarity
on something rather i mean again here it
does say that when you've got an appeal
going for non-determination or rather if
there's a non-determination it seems to
be the procedures for this are similar
to those which apply when an application
has been refused
does that mean it's the applicant's
right to determine the route they want
to go or the authority can as well
thank you
to you chairman um
both sides are given the opportunity to
put forward the type of appeal that they
want yeah um the decision ultimately
will be with the inspectorate
the inspectorate may feel that you know
looking at the at the nature of the case
uh the the interest involved they feel
it would either be for written reps
um for a hearing or public inquiry
whatever it might be yeah it's just that
we give our side the fact that the
appellant has stead in their in their
appeal application and that's all it is
it's an aptly just the application
um they want it as written reps that
doesn't mean it will be a written reps
um
appeal yeah
thank you chairman
what remembers can we move on
thank you
are we going to make that request then
chairman sorry we'll make that request
on the part of the authority that's
important will be made that it will be
for a um hearing okay thank you
thank you
the unreasonable noise impact because of
the hours as much as anything i mean i
think that's everybody has agreed on
that
between 8am and 6am would be
is one thing but
before 8am and after 6pm is another
thing and i mean
somebody who has my own
industrial use making my own amount of
noise and i sympathize entirely with
neighbours so
thank you
okay yep right thank you very much
hi members we'll move on gender item six
sunnyside stoney hills burnham on crouch
it's uh the proposal is to demolish an
existing house and ancillary structures
in the erection of two new dwellings
there's a recommendation to approve
thank you chairman
so
yes that's it
um the application site is located
outside the development boundaries of
burnham crowds towards the western side
of the area known as stony hills
the site is known as sunnyside and it
currently comprises a detached bungalow
as you can see on those plants with a
detached
garage so these are the elevations of
the existing bungalow
and the floor plans
and and planning permission is short for
the demolition of the existing bungalow
and the erection of two three-bedroom
sale style dwellings
and here are the plans this is the
block plan
elevations
floor plans
and the roof plan
[Music]
they're actually handed so there isn't
much of a difference between the two
plots
again four plants and the roof plan
this is the street scene elevation
here existing compose and these are some
photographs this is the existing
bungalow on the side
here is the
garage
the touchdowns
and this is the neighboring property to
the north
here is the view from the road
there is development behind this
hedgerow development
the application side you can just barely
see it here and fairview is down to the
south
so the proposed development has been
assessed against the policies of the ldp
and has taken into account all material
planning considerations including the
previous permissions and appeals for
similar residential
development allowed within the area of
sony hills
on this basis it is considered that the
principle of erecting two dwellings
within the area of sony hills is
acceptable having regard to the
established character of the surrounding
area the proposal would not have it is
not considered that it would have a
discord an impact to the character of
the area or the intrinsic beauty of the
surrounding countryside
following the publication of the
office's report further comments from
the environmental health team theme were
received highlighting the need for a
pre-commencement condition ensuring the
investigation
and risk
submission of an investigation and risk
assessment in terms of the contamination
and this is set out within the members
update
an agreement to the suggested
pre-commencement conditions was after
received after the publication of the
members update
furthermore it is noted that conditions
in relation to ecology mitigation and
enhancement enhancement measures as well
as one for the installation of sensitive
lighting scheme have been suggested by
the ecology consultant
and which are also considered reasonable
to be imposed
so
officers recommend approval of the
application subject to the conditions on
pages 46-48
in the agenda
the additional condition on page four of
the members update as well as the three
suggested conditions by the ecological
consultant
thank you very much uh before i move on
to members we have
one person who has registered to speak
remotely via teams and that's the agent
mr tony cousin
you have this cousin you have two
minutes as i'm sure you already know
you look like you're in the uh in a cave
it's very very dark
oh
german i'm more interested in what mr
cousins has got to say hello we have two
minutes
when you start
um
um
um
um
thank you mr cousin
thanks mr chandler
thank you chairman i would have been
hearing the members first but well i
know i'm not going to comment on the
application chat i'm i'm actually not
going to partake in this
because i've just studied this
surrounding hour and mr cousins has
mentioned the name of the property and
even though i looked at the site
i'd rather not because um the property
next door i have been acquainted i
believe
with that person well the person's next
door and i'd rather not participate in
now this um
application bearing in mind
can i put it an event that occurred so
thank you
okay thank you shannon
all right burnham members who's first
canceled
um yeah thank you chairman could i just
ask the officers hasn't a recent
application on stony hill hill's just
been a recommended refusal from the
officers please can i have clarity on
that before i speak any further
sorry
if there was a refusal
it was recommended for refusal
do you know what do you know what the
site was i can't remember but i know
when i saw it i thought my goodness
oh
three term you might actually refer to
one that i talked with
before i went so um
you might you might be referring to the
one on behind sunnyside two two
bungalows behind sunnyside but that was
that was allowed on appeal if that's the
one that you're referring to there was
one up here there was one application
which was refused um
to
uh
demolish the
actually not demolished to erect two
bungalows at the back that was two back
in 2016
and that was dismissed on appeal and
there was a following one for two
bungalows at the back of sunnyside uh
which was allowed on appeal and then
after that
um
and according to the um officer's report
there was another one to build four
houses at the back of
um hillside and
sunnyside which was also approved
yeah okay thank you but i wish i'd have
remembered to write it down because i
can remember reading it and i'm sure
it's only recently that an officer's
recommendation to refuse property anyway
chairman let's move on um i actually had
a quite a good chat with the bin laurie
people suez the other day
and um sorry sorry they have a real
torrid time trying to collect up there
now
and i know you're going to say it's not
reasons for planning refusals but it to
me it's sustainability you you're
putting more and more houses up there
you're supposed to be saying you know
we're working within um the parameters
of the facilities in burnham on crouch
but what are we up to there now how many
houses have we got on stony hills my
post bag is still constantly full of
people who are complaining on mill mill
road i walked down there the other day
because i i always used to do when i was
the mayor i'd drive around to see what
was going on i don't even go down
stanley hills very often now because he
can't turn around i've got horrible gas
guzzler so cancel fluke before he says
anything to me so i can hardly turn
around when i get down there there's no
pla passing places unless you go on to
people's frontage because you know we've
heard of all the instances down there
um and i just think it's yet again more
houses and an area that i still feel
you're going to argue with me as much as
you like i don't really mind my view is
i still think it's not sustainable i
think putting more pick more houses up
there
that road is classed as an unclassified
road regardless of whether it's
tarmacked or not it's not supported by
the highways there's no footpaths or
pavements it's not safe for the kids to
walk to school you have got people who's
moved into those houses and they've got
three four children and they're
complaining all the time they've got
nowhere to step out of the way when the
traffic's going up there and yes it may
not be planning reason for refusal
chairman but it's the fact of life at
stony hills and we have got a duty of
care to our residents if we keep
granting planning permissions get some
footpaths down there get something so
they can walk there get some joining
from the side at the back going to um
at the back way there's a footpath it's
covered in bomb brambles and briars you
can't get anywhere from there unless you
go via mill road we've got problems with
speeding we've got problems where the
the lorries are actually knocking down
electricity pylons where they get you
know telegraph electricity pylons where
people are having power outages for at
least 12 hours yeah and okay you can say
it's a rare occasion chairman but when
they go down i'm telling you something
my email is full of complaints now i'm
more than happy if it happens again to
forward it on to the officers chairman
they're my reasons whether you think
they're
valid planning ones is a different
matter i uh but bearing in mind that
we've got government inspectors who said
that the area is sustainable i don't
think that would stack up for long so we
need to be very careful about making a
decision on those grounds cancer schemes
uh i have to second what uh council
stanford saying the road is has been
unsuitable ever since planning started
down here
everybody says it's not a planning
reason i can't think of a more important
planning reason than accessibility there
are no footpaths there's no lighting the
road is uh yes at the moment it's made
up but it's not as
made up by essex county council so it
could become unmade up it's just wrong
and the whole town thinks it's wrong
all right
that's mrs hall
thank you um
it looks like we will lose the if we do
say no anyway but that i think council
stamps right if we are going to have to
do it this footpath's in there and
especially bridley ways is part of our
country bit that we used to ride over
and we've got nothing so if we if we're
going to have to lose it which we most
probably will when it went to appeal can
we put down that we have these other
amenities at least
that's without the doctors and all the
schools that haven't got enough places
problem that we have is we've got to
come up with reasons that the inspector
will
support
the very work at the very least we run
the risk of having costs against us if
we do
make a decision
to refuse that um
that an inspector thinks is unreasonable
because other inspectors have said for
instance it is a sustainable site so
we maybe we do need to be very mindful
how we make any decision to refuse on
this
that's the trouble but if we can say we
stipulate these other things perhaps you
know least we can meet halfway
we need to be able to produce the
evidence county highways will not
support us on it and they are the
highways
professionals
and um
so for sustainability it's uh
it's other inspectors have said it's
sustainable so we can't you cannot fight
that
that information from other professional
bodies unless we are
willing to spend huge sums of money
finding our own professional bodies to
counter
claim it and the costs just do not stack
up on that cancer chairman just before
um councillor fluka comes in can i just
say i have tried to get essex county
council to adopt that
and there's no way they they will do it
i had quite a lot of um
residents write to me and ask if there
was any possibility that we could
improve that because it is what it is we
know it's a massive development now but
i mean as far as i'm concerned we should
be trying and i i did try to get the
road adopted and get some lighting etc
to try and make it more livable in this
day and age as far as i'm concerned and
acceptable but essex county council
won't won't do it
no the county council will will not
adopt anything of that sort these days
um but it would cost them huge sums of
money to do so
and um they they would not be willing to
get involved in that
council fluker
thank you
look
this is um i'm surprised um
hasn't used my famous words i know i
just looked online i just looked online
for an alternative but you know there
isn't one so i'm not going to say um
german look you know
my first question is in relation to
5.4.5 because i'm i'm i'm minded of an
appeal that i've i've read recently
where a planning inspector criticizes
members
for not going to look at planning
application sites i mean i've pretty
much done it all the time
um you know to make an informed decision
you really need to go to the site and i
did actually go to the site the other
day and have a look and i did notice
that the houses behind um are actually
occupied yet the report says uh they
haven't come forward yet so perhaps the
officer can confirm before i ask another
question
did an officer attend this side
through ceremony i yes as far as i'm
aware i'm i'm not the case officer of
this application but i have had
confirmation this morning from
um the officer that she carried out a
side visit and these are the photographs
from the side visit and that they were
not the the houses were not built but as
i say
i
i was in the case officer so i didn't
personally carry out the site visit okay
thank you so chairman
i mean i i hear what the members say and
i hear about the footpaths and you know
i can remember stone hills as
you know it's a
teenager uh and we all know how much
it's changed and i mean it has been said
before in this committee that it was
this committee actually that started all
this development there but can i just
remind everybody that murray fields
which was the first uh
development there was was actually
granted permission by the fan inspector
so chairman i
look the officers report refers to all
the previous planning inspector
decisions
it is a sustainable location i hear what
you say about roads footpath lights and
everything else but it is very much a
lifestyle choice for people that that
want to buy houses there you know these
aren't planning reasons and i'm i'm also
mindful of what mr kenman the the
secretary of state's planning inspector
mr kenmon lane said about office members
of this council manufacturing reasons
for refusing planning applications
and chairman we need to be very very
careful i think the officer's report is
is right
and that said chairman i would propose
that we agree the officer's
recommendation because there are no
planning reasons to turn this down
i mean the point is i mean surely i mean
we've heard from bernard members that
residents down there are upset because
there's no footpath there's no this
there's no street lights there's no that
nobody's forced anyone to go and live
down there they make that decision
themselves a very commercial decision to
spend a huge amount of money to go and
live down there it's too late to
complain after the event
that's
hell
as you've taken it right okay
so anybody else wish to speak on that
in that case we have a proposal
from cancer fluka duly seconded by
councillor helm
to
oh sorry cancer boys to
agree the officer's recommendation to
approve for the
reasons given and for the conditions at
the back those in favor of that please
show
are those against
okay five two so that is approved
thank you members we'll move on to
agenda items seven which is
the old clubhouse the key burnham on
crouch variation of condition on plans
on approved application
uh mr johnson i believe this one's yours
i'll be reading it
you've taken responsibility for it
someone just excuse me for filling with
the uh presentation are
you used to doing
thank you chairman
um
can if we can go to the next one you
know the initial page just
thank you chairman um members may well
re recall this application which was
considered
uh previously
the uh
the single development issue on this uh
site is the installation of railings
and
i think if we just go straight to the
drawings because the matter just
concerns a change in the railing type
and that is what is effectively before
members so if we can just scroll down
um
go down again please
um right
there should be
right
okay
um
this this drawing here members would
have seen it in the um presentation that
was circulated shows the proposed
railings
they are of a different style
to that which was considered previously
and rejected
by members
different in terms of its style and
difference in terms of its height
it is of a much reduced scale
practically half the size of the
previous
proposed radiance
and that is effectively what is in front
of members today
thank you chairman
okay thank you very much
we have two people wishing to speak in
person on this tonight the first is
reporter
miss diana
[Music]
and uh when you're ready you have two
minutes from the time you start speaking
thank you do i have to press a button
okay
diana bailey owner of the adjacent
building the otter heart and previous
objector
and all i really wanted to say tonight
was how grateful i am to
to see our neighbours the applicant have
taken on board our concerns
by showing a lower height railing and
propose a more transparent solution
we very much hope that there will be an
almost uninterrupted view of the otter
heart west elevation from the key
and i also wanted just to
reiterate a 100 with the conservation
officer
by requesting large-scale drawings of
the proposed railing illustrating
dimensions of the individual components
and finer details in order to show a
sensitive design
and construction of the railings and how
it abuts to the otter hut it should be
noted in future we will need access for
maintenance therefore adequate space
must be allowed between the end of the
railings and the otter heart
thank you
very much
and we have a second speaker which is
the agent mr chris rag
if you'd like to take your place of the
microphone
ask before you have two minutes from the
time you start speaking
good evening
um like it's been said you may record a
previous version of this application
which was heard by this committee
the application saw aurelia
uh saw the railing above the seaboard to
protect the public from the dangers of
the slipway and the applicant's new high
voltage slipway equipment whilst
protecting
the expensive equipment from any
potential trespassers
the railing proposed at the time was 1.1
metres higher than the sea wall
and some 2.4 meters higher than the
ground level
i drew criticism from the planning
committee and was subsequently refused
if i could be so bold to loosely quote
what was said during the meeting
it was too high and should be
significantly lower and if i recall
suggested two feet lower
it should be a maximum of 1.8 meters
high from the ground level not the 2.4
and it was suggested that the design of
the railing
needed to be reviewed
instead of appealing that decision we
listen to the comments and are keen to
provide a sensitive design
that adds to the character whilst
protecting the public
and the new slip by equipment
therefore we have reduced to the height
of the railing by two feet
and it now peaks at 1.8 meters above the
ground level although it's lower in
places
and we have changed the design to tell
one of the fascinated stories of the
town's history the vanguard restoration
restoration foundation charity which
aims to bring back the life
bring back to life the dunkirk little
ship which sets out from burnham on
crouch to rescue survivors from the
beaches of dunkirk
project that the applicant is heavily
involved in
the design of the railing depicts the
jungkook little ship and will be crafted
by one of the last remaining master
blacksmiths in essex
tim harrison council's heritage officer
has supported the proposal
and as just suggested um the large-scale
drawings that buy condition will uh is
welcomed
um suitable permits will be obtained by
the ea to ensure that the
railings will be erected without
compromising
members
is your world cancer screens you can go
um okay well very briefly uh last time
this came up i didn't i wasn't at the
debate and wouldn't have taken part in
it because i've been involved in the
whole
public debate
this time around i've not talked to
anybody about it
and i think that uh
these railings are fine i like i have to
also declare that i'm also a trustee of
the vanguard restoration trust so uh so
therefore i must be careful what i say
but i like the idea i'm bound to i guess
um but
i i have no objections and i'm delighted
to hear that uh the neighbor also has no
objections
yeah thanks mr sister thank you thank
you chairman um i'd actually like to
congratulate them that they actually
went away rather than go to appeal it's
really nice when people engage within
the community i know not everybody will
be pleased about having railings but i
actually would like to make a suggestion
when you speak to the environment um
agency can you ask them to match what
you're putting up for the stuff that
they've already put up for longer key it
might actually then go in tandem and
look quite nice
um
so
i actually do um support this
application chairman again
cancer fluke shame not to um yeah
chairman i don't have any problems with
this at all i think the the new owners
of this who took this property i think
of from harry trump and clearly they've
you know they've really turned this into
quite something and i think they should
be commended for that
um and i think the railings are very
popular variety of reasons including
planning but i think that
um mrs lewis alluded to a point that and
it i'm sorry i just flipped through the
conditions i didn't see it but
maybe
the officer perhaps can guide me you'll
enjoy that um
about whether or not we can have a
condition whereby the final design of
the railings are signed off by
our conservation officer
i can hear someone saying yes
uh sorry i didn't quite hear but um just
repeat what you asked uh council fluency
so with regards to the rainings can we
have a condition in there to say that
the final design of the railings are to
be signed off by our conservation
officer
just give me one second please just um
uh top of my head i would think you
would have to because say it could be to
the satisfaction of the conservation
office so i don't think we can ask a
conservation officer and effect to
design it
through your chair well while there's
not
a sign of process as such details as
received will be reviewed
by the conservation officer and officers
will have due regard to the
recommendations of the conservation
officer
i'm sure mrs lewis will write to him so
any other members and i propose we will
approve it as per the officer's
recommendation
yeah but i think yes i think council mrs
stanford has already basically suggested
the same thing but okay any other
members
in that case those in favor of approving
the application as per of the
recommendation
any against in that case it is approved
thank you members gender item eight
the moorings sea view parade st lawrence
single story rear extensions two-story
rear extension and first floor additions
to the front and rear
uh there's a recommendation to refuse
for the reasons detailed in section
eight of this report
and hello i'd just like to make the
memes aware of a of a change there was
an error in the report with regards to
the reason for refusal um it was worded
incorrectly an administrative error um
it should have read the post proposed
development due to its location size
height and design would be an
unsympathetic in congress addition to
the existing dwelling which would harm
the character and the appearance of the
host dwelling and the surrounding area
contrary to policies d1 and h4 of the
modern dish northern district local
development plan and the guidance
contained within the national policy
national planning policy framework
okay
so the moorings is um
for the app for this application six
householder planning permission for a
single story rear extension single
storyboard extensions two-story rear
extension and first floor additions to
the front and rear the application site
is located on the north eastern side of
sea view parade and is located within
the settlement boundary of st lawrence
the site is occupied by a detached
bungalow
this application is a resubmission of a
previously refused application
submitted scheme has been altered by the
reduction in the ridge height by 0.6
meters together with a reduction in the
height of the first floor extension to
the front elevation by 0.2 meters all
other proposed works remain the same
this is the location of the property
within seaview parade
this is the site plan which shows the
proposed works
these are the existing and proposed side
elevations
the existing and front rear renovations
this is the proposed front and rear
elevations
and these are the existing and pro side
elevations from the previously refused
scheme
these are the proposed uh front and rear
elevations from the previously refused
scheme
this is the existing ground floor and
roof plan
the proposed ground floor plan
the proposed ground floor plan from the
previous
previously refused scheme
the proposed roof and first floor plan
proposed roof and festival plan from the
previously refused scheme
the proposed sections
and the proposed sections from the
previously refused scheme
so what's the last one this is a
view
from the entrance of sea view parade so
at the very start
this is a view
at the end of sea view parade outside of
water's edge
this is the views of the application
site
from within various parts of sea view
parade
the application site is here
over here in this
photo here and here
there were some more views from the
opposite side of the
entrance of the way this is a photo of
the site from the rear of the garden so
we have the application site here the
neighboring property collins say
and the neighbouring property happy days
this is a size a view from the back of
the property facing the neighboring
property at collins say
and facing the neighboring property
happy days
and these are some of the various other
house styles that are within the sea
view parade
this is within sea view parade this is
in
the road
behind
the backs on sea view parade
this is a view down sea view parades we
can see waterside sports
center at the end
this is leading out of seaview parade
and this is a view from
wick farm road looking in and this is
the entrance of sea view parade and this
is where the site notice was positioned
for this application
that was it so it's it's concluded that
um the proposed first four editions for
a reason of their location size heights
and design would be an incongruous and
dominant addition which would harm the
character and appearance of the dwelling
and the surrounding area the amendments
of the scheme are not considered to be
of such extent as to reduce the scan of
the development or improve the design to
such a degree as to overcome the reasons
for refusal stated above
it is therefore considered that the
prose development is not in accordance
with the relevant policies contained
within the ldp
thank you
we have one
personal machine to speak
on this and this is the agent mr michael
lewis
lewis you know the rules
you have two minutes from the time you
start speaking give us a moment set the
timer up
sea view parade is a secluded cul-de-sac
in which the homes face the homes facing
northeast all enjoy unprecedented views
across lawrence bay
they've been variously extended since
their construction in the 1930s and many
already have roof space accommodation
added including those either side of the
moorings
this application is a resubmission of
the earlier scheme refused by a reason
of its location size height design being
incongruous and dominant harming the
character and appearance of the dwelling
in the surrounding area
the scheme has responded by reducing the
rays bridge height by by just two feet
two feet above the existing ridge and by
simplifying the roof to the rear
officers have stated they're happy with
the ground floor extension and all the
new first floor accommodation is now
entirely within the pitched roof space
the original house has already been much
adapted with multiple extensions leaving
little clue of the original form
the effect has been to create a
complicated arrangement of multiple
gable ends facing front and rear and
eaves at varying levels
the design intention is to retain as far
as possible the front elevation
the kerbin sea view parade and
neighboring buildings and existing
boundary treatments means there's no
distant view of the house
the modest two feet raising of the main
ridge would be barely perceptible with
the line of sight from the road raised
by less than two degrees
other than the dormer window to the
front the extension works proposed would
be entirely private to the rear and
invisible in the public realm
there'd be no adverse effect on the
neighbor's privacy or overlooking
there have been no public objections and
the paris chunk and it's supported by
the parish council
we believe this is a scheme that's
comfortable in its setting with no ill
effect on the street scene or the
character of the neighborhood the
applicant as a young and growing family
is currently required to work from home
approval of this scheme would provide
the necessary space to enable him and
his family to remain in the house they
love
hello it's your two minutes thank you
so it's a matter of clarity before we
start can the officer confirm
that this is the conservation area
no i think the recommendation has been
changed because i
loaded that myself is that correct there
isn't a conservation of it yes
yes that's correct the reason for
refusal status in the agenda is
incorrect i mean it's not within a
conservation area
board members
council mr channel
uh yes thank you very much chairman
um having seen the officers report and
they'll see the previous application
um
now um i called this to committee
because
obviously um i was aware that i was
aware of the parish council support
actually on both occasions
and i have to say chairman i have
actually been out i didn't go on the
site
i have been well i mean i know the area
but i go and refresh my memory
and i have walked around i think it's a
bit of a shame with all honesty
we haven't actually got a photograph of
the property waters edge
which is actually
i know we've seen next door but actually
the officer did refer to it and took a
photo standing outside water's edge but
somewhat of a pity we haven't actually
got a photo because water's edge is
quite a significant substantial dwelling
of two floors and actually it has um
dormer windows which are right on a
boundary which overlook actually the
stone sailing club ground and also if
you walk along the beach at the back yes
there's quite a high rise going up to
the gardens but you can see water's edge
does have
actually two floors because they've got
the lovely window where obviously they
like to look and look over the wonderful
view of i'm saying
uh the the agent has pointed out some
points which i think are very very
important i have to say i feel the
officer and i'm going to say this i know
the agency was correcting the refusal of
the first uh design however i have to
say i do differ
in that i do feel the mitigations that
have been applied in terms of the the
ridge height and reductions thereof and
the actual mitigation that has now
occurred due to the design put before us
i if you look at the proposal that's on
the table now and what was before
i think there has been quite significant
improvement
st lawrence is an area i'm sure members
will know of a multitude of different
designs all over and sea view parade
itself is not alone
in fact one of the other dwellings has a
quite high ridge height which the
officer sort of pointed out
and
the there's no projection in front of
the house actually i think the officer's
report referred to a projection in front
of the property my um from what i can
see that's not the case at all the
extension there's nothing and the door
window coming forward he's not going to
project forward um you can see actually
the exist you should be able to see an
existing roof height i think have you
got something showing that
um
yes now and then can you show the
refusal um that's quite a good one
actually can you show the refusal that
you refused
yeah and now show what's proposed
and
yeah
and to go through the proposal
when you compare the two to me
um what is on the table now is much
better
and hearing about the ridge height but
reductions are just slightly above the
existing reach height and that actually
won't be visible
from the roadway as such um in terms of
the extension extensions mostly at the
rear
and so the ridge height is just there
but you're not going to see a great big
ridge height sticking in front of you
and i've stood exactly at the points
where the office has been i've walked
right round both ways i've been right
down to the beach and going around the
back but as i say it's a pity we haven't
got a photo of water's edge because
that's quite a significant dwelling
two-story with dormer windows and with a
viewing area at the back i mean it's a
habitable room
so chairman i have to say on balance and
hearing um the officer's view
i actually do now support um the
application as it is and i i do agree
with the parish council's view on this
and they were supportive of it as i say
on both occasions thank
you cancer hell do you wish to
welcome
i did
counselor chance i couldn't sleep out of
my way
she said everything i would have said
but i'll save some time then
but you need to split your microphone on
cancer health
microphone
i have no problem with this application
at all thank you thank you
council fluker
thank you
um little bit disappointing that maybe
the the agent didn't supply a rendering
looking from the river but i you know i
sail past here a lot and and i
photographed it well i could have done
it um
but when i uh when i saw mr lewis was
dealing with this i thought well and he
knows how fond i am of anchor cottage i
was concerned and i can hear him
laughing um but in tinock's lane i don't
know how it's happened we've got some
ghastly looking buildings there from the
river but as far as this one's concerned
german and um i don't have a problem
with that i think it will sit in
perfectly from the river and i think
it's so important that when we've got
developments that looking across the
river and i'm sure there'll be others
come forward like this you know perhaps
the agents should be encouraged to um
provide some renderings or some shots
from the river because it is important
and and i i'm i mean given the uh
shyness of the two world members
chairman um i'll
propose chairman that
contrary to the members the officer's
recommendation to refuse i propose
chairman that we do approve this uh on
the grounds that it is subjective you
know we know it's subjective and you you
have your views and the members have
their views
but um chairman i think that it it does
meet the criteria of local development
plan policy d1 uh and it does fit in
with its surroundings chairman and i'm
not sure that mrs chan has said it in so
many words but i didn't understand that
she was all in favor of it no no i
didn't search him i was letting other
members i think you knew my view and it
was coming so i thank councillor fluke
for saying the world members are shy no
we're not shy and we would have liked
the other opportunity to come back when
the other members were perhaps given a
view and i'm sure we would have proposed
and seconded
that's where i was coming from i
indicated yeah before we move on mr
johnson wishes to say something uh
through your chair thank you just a
point of clarification on one of council
channel's comments um in the office's
report where it talks about projections
it wasn't projections
in front of the building is a projection
into the roof
that that that's the point that was
being oh that's sorry then i misread
that because i i registered was
projecting forward yeah just weekly
officer had no objection as the uh as
the agent pointed out with the
extensions around um that the ground
floor the objections and exactly and
really there's no concerns about
elements in the roof yeah uh there's
the the the main thing which was pointed
out particularly in 5.2.6 was the
extension of the rendering
from the ground floor into the roof and
in office's view that led to a lack of
cohesion so that was the point that was
being made by officers thank you
chairman well thank you for clarifying
that i mean i would say the officer's
report
didn't seem to have too many negatives
about there was nothing to do with
residential loss of immunity either side
at such a vast site
um the article four couldn't be applied
um at all that had no influence there
and it was so it just seemed to be um
the officer considered it was
incongruous i agree with the first
refusal as i said when i've studied
these um plans obviously online as you
can do
and i do agree with the office there
however as i said
on balance um i feel that what's been
done
uh to bring this forward with the
improvements that have been made in my
view then i i can see in my eyes it
should be approved so i will propose
okay so i can make it clear thank you
all right members any anybody wishes sue
wishes to discuss this any further
otherwise we have a proposal we have a
proposal duly seconded you can decide
between yourselves who did it the
proposal duly seconded
to
overturn the office of recommendation to
refuse and to approve the application
now
for what reasons please
well i i council proposed it so he's got
to give the reasons
and and the the
the design size and scale and bulk which
is referenced in policy d1 um
you know that criteria is met german and
therefore it is acceptable thank you
i mean i want the normal conditions
chairman obviously because we have to
show that
but um
i think you know
and in fact there was reference mater um
some of the the materials but i think
for condition wise i think we have the
normal conditions that's per normal but
the reason is because the committee
believes that it will fit well in this
yeah scene and the river scene
and that has overcome the previous
reasons of refusal i do think that's
what it's done
mr johnson through you just for a point
of clarification uh and counselor fluker
we rely on uh on just d1 or his d1 and
h4
that's h4
i mean i think the the thing about d1
and h4 you can use them to refuse and
approve so it's that
effective yes
please show
there's no one against so in that case
that is agreed
thank you
[Music]
um
before i move on has anybody got
anything they wish to add no
right in that case agenda item nine any
other items of business the chairman of
the committee decides are urgent i have
none
counselor fluker german first of all and
can i apologize all the members here
because um we should congratulate you
back into your rightful elevation as the
chairman of this committee said well
done
chairman can i say that bearing in mind
the previous chairman refused to have a
meeting with an informal meeting with
officers regarding enforcement within
the southeastern area can i ask you to
consider that request yes and hopefully
bring it forward thank you mr johnson is
here he's hopefully listening yes we do
the committee has decided that before we
do wish to have a
some form of meeting to discuss um the
horrific enforcement list
thank you chairman i mean just through
that obviously this has been mentioned
before
um there is there is there is
deliberations uh amongst us on how um
communication on enforcement matters and
discussing it with members can be taken
forward
but i was going to close the meeting at
nine o'clock but you've moved on so it's
now 901 i closed the meeting thank you
members and public